this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck as focused
as bad words
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Melbourne
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist we're here with
another simpleton that's right
Jamie Keil Steen is here in the studio
hi everybody hi everybody he's back once
again so we're all a little bit gullible
and foolish and that's why we're all the
simpletons really I like it that was
also like the first time that I've
accepted how I've been introduced
because of being self-hating whenever
people are like hilarious comedian I'm
like oh that's not gonna that let's set
the bar lower and when you were like
simpleton I was like word don't worry
we're the King simpletons King and King
simpleton great now Jamie is a comedian
you get to decide whether or not he's
hilarious yeah well in interviews
usually whenever I'm set up like when I
when I used to have to do like remember
like wacky morning radio was always like
why don't I've done way too many well it
would be like rock and roll stations and
they're like it's fartin the girl and
then it was just like a bunch of guys
like yelling at this poor woman at like
6:00 in the morning with a dyke pounded
breakfast burritos they would always
yeah like try to cue me up for bits and
in real life like I like doing I like
talking to you guys like I talking about
real things so that always be like
hilarious man then Jamie Hill Steen and
be like what have you been thinking
about I'm like a institutional racism
war crime it would just get so dark like
wait that's not funny alright see me
tonight at the chuckle Factory
all right so Jamie will beat the chuckle
hut this Wednesday Wednesday now here's
the thing the reason I wanted to have
Jamie on to talk about this specific
topic because it is a difficult topic in
the new book we're working on love
people use things we there's a chapter
in there about the truth and and really
the truth is the one of the most
difficult things to talk about Kafka
said that you can discuss the truth only
through jokes and I think it's why
people like Dave Chappelle or Anthony
Jeselnik even who is an absurdist or
drew michael is another one of my
favorite comedians Jerrod Carmichael is
phenomenal they approximate the truth
through humor so hopefully we'll be able
to use some humor today to talk about a
very serious subject today we're going
to talk about dealing with toxic people
we're gonna talk about defining
reassessing repairing and also letting
go of toxic relationships now I think
this is gonna be one this is gonna be a
classic episode I feel I can feel it
right now because this topic comes up a
lot III all the questions today by the
way Jamie they they came from the
birthplace of toxicity Facebook yeah
yeah I'm great so I went to Facebook I
just said hey we're doing absolutely
doing with toxic people and it's ply the
probably the most popular thing we put
on Facebook in the last month Oh what is
so depressing right yeah but it makes
total sense we have so many questions
we'll get to as many as we can here on
this minimal episode and then we'll
address the rest on the maximum will get
even more personal there before we dive
into our first question I want to
apologize for my facial hair you're so
cute when you try and grow because you
forgot to shave this morning watching
this on YouTube feel free to roast me in
the comments below it does that is that
beard is it looks like your 16 year old
self growing a beard which
coincidentally you still look about 16
years old right and I've been doing this
little app that tells us what you what
your age looks like in your photos and
I'll just text him like never forget
yeah and it'll be like Josh look
standing right next to you I'm 27 and
Ryan is always 40 in every photo
44 no matter what right no Matt
when that picture was taken it's always
like 40 but you know that's I've always
liked post-pubescent always looked like
5 to 10 years older than beer things
great it's like it's it's a quarantine
look it's an evil twin look if like you
wanted to kind of like jump the shark
with the minimalist it's also a
disgraced politician disappears for two
years then comes back for a CNN
interview look that's my favorite like
Bill Richardson the governor when he
after he lost her present Al Gore when
he came back remember he had like that
huge beer yes and I was just kind of
like is how cool I'm a [ __ ] tribe you
could have like growing your hair out it
would have been even better no dude you
have the perfect disheveled look man it
is very endearing like you can pull I
wish I could pull off Barry's disheveled
like that well I don't know like I don't
I haven't cut it at all I don't know
what to I don't know what to do because
I do kind of want to grow it out cuz I
like it messy like this I was talking
about this I did my first show his back
the other day and I was talking about
this on stage where I've you guys know
me / like on and off the show and you
know it's been very hard for me to just
date and I used to jump into
relationships very very very fast and
but every time I try to just be like I'm
just gonna be a guy I'm gonna hook up I
always end up in relationships and it's
because of what you said where I had
this realization that it's because like
I'm not like hot guy you want to bang in
a bar attractive I'm like like baby
broken bird who needs to be nursed back
to health attractive where girls are
like we have to help him and they beat
him and like he cries too baby yo two
memes like I do so like that's why I
attract it it's that like endearing like
oh but it's not like yeah look at him
it's working morons like that like your
friend Colin our friend Carl from
minimally Simo who are bar who are
taking home from a bar in bang huh no
there's just like you know I would stop
my life to pursue this person yeah but
that can actually be toxic behavior it
is well no no absolutely 100% and so
let's let's dive into our first question
right now instead of voicemail I got all
of these from Facebook Eva in London has
a question for us Ryan what's your
definition of a tux
person is it a type of person or rather
a kind of behavior that appears in
certain relationships is it possible
that I could be a toxic person to you
but a really sincere and lovely person
to many others yes interesting so let me
let me give you the definition of toxic
and I have this in our it's the the
people chapter of love people use things
which by the way I just turned in the
the third draft last night is coming out
in graduation I started the fourth draft
this morning about 5:00 a.m. perfect and
so the final chapter it's it's a
relationship book but it's about the
different relationships we have with
ourself so whether it's with the truth
or with our stuff that's sort of the
first relationship we tackle in there
there are the relationship with our self
the relationship with values or money or
creativity or distractions or technology
but then also it ends with our
relationship with people right and I
think one of the things that comes up
time and time again is how do we deal
and how do we identify what is a toxic
person and so the definition that I have
in the book is a toxic a toxic
relationship is a harmful or unharmed
for or unpleasant in a pervasive and/or
insidious way so a toxic relationship is
harmful or unpleasant in a pervasive or
insidious way they could have just said
all of Jamie's relationships well I
think that's that that's a thing like
it's if if every relationship tends to
end up toxic yeah now we need to define
relationships as well because I disagree
with what you're saying I mean obviously
you're joking but like both you and I
have a relationship it's in the rise not
right it's not a sexual intimate
relationship one out of you yet now that
you have that beard it is sexy fourth
draft beard and so I'll dive a little
bit more into the book a little bit
later on but let's talk about how do we
identify toxic relationships yeah well I
think that I mean the the first thing
before I forget ava is the the very last
part of her question I thought was
really interesting which was can I
beaded toxic to someone in particular
yeah I think she might be talking about
and you guys tell me if I'm if I'm wrong
on this but you could be triggering to
somebody sure without necessarily like
being a toxic person I think that's kind
of maybe what she's describing cuz look
there are toxic people who as famed
philosopher Miley Cyrus says come in
like a wrecking ball and we'll just like
mess up your [ __ ] right and like those
times a lot of times those people are
narcissistic they're selfish they just
the kind of people who just suck your
lifeforce and have to bring you down to
I mean I've had relationships where not
only were girls jealous of like my
friends or jujitsu but they were jealous
like if I meditated they didn't like if
I meditated by anything that would make
me better and therefore more capable of
leaving you know and but then where it
my fault was I was like codependent that
I'm like oh well if this really hot girl
is crazy enough to do that she's not
gonna leave me so hooray and like we
would both just like enable each other
so like I think but if she like let's
say Ava is Eva Eva sorry let's say Eva
is in a relationship and she has a bunch
of guy friends and you know the person
she's dating that triggers something
where you know he had a girlfriend who
used to like cheat a lot or whatever
like that's not her fault that's just
maybe their lives aren't compatible you
know what I mean so like my definition
of if you are in a toxic relationship I
think the first thing I think of is
someone who is consistently making you
feel less than who's not pushing you to
be your best self and who you feel like
like quicksand you feel like it's just
kind of dragging you down and you feel
just trapped in the relationship totally
I think the opposite of that Eva is are
you a person who shows respect do you
show compassion do you show that you
understand the other person because if
you're doing that that's a surefire way
to assure that you are not a toxic
person I found the last part of her
question interesting too because
oftentimes we can be around people and
get mad about the same thing well it
might be too toxic people who are
getting angry about a certain issue and
feeding off each other's toxicity right
so the I'd like to just I'd like to put
a pin in that for a second and say it's
possible and I think in most cases I
would stop looking for the toxic person
mm-hm and we're gonna call this episode
toxic people because there are toxic
people but most of the time a toxic
person is really just a series or maybe
even just one toxic behavior it's just
like it but if I put a spoonful of
strychnine into a stew the entire thing
becomes toxic the stew isn't by
definition toxic but when I put the
strychnine in there all of a sudden now
you have this poison I thought you were
gonna say that is just a toxic behavior
and I'm like no bro that's a toxic
person if you're putting strychnine in
this field yeah that's a really really
good point I mean yeah you have people
who are just bad people they just they
feel bad about themselves and so they
need to drag their partner down to their
level and that I would consider toxic
but you're right for the most part it is
just there are certain behaviors you
know like I always say his name wrong
but uh allen de de de pumped or our de
bolt on there it is Alain de Botton he
always talks about how in relationships
we expect these you know we want the
romantic comedy we want the the soulmate
we want these perfect relationships we
try to put on sort of an image of what
we think they want our best self to look
like in the first couple of dates and
then you know a month or two and you
have your first fight and sorry if you
get this like oh this like sick to your
stomach like oh what's happening again I
thought this is gonna be perfect when in
reality you should look at relationships
as being like okay here's all of my
crazy what's all of your crazy cool can
this be compatible can this work you
know and I really do like that because I
think that a relationship at its best is
too broken people trying to live the
best lives they can and trying to help
each other and trying to lift each other
and you know I I do like that but you
watch enough romantic comedies where I
mean there's part of me that thinks like
romantic comedies are like more
dangerous than porn you know what I mean
like porn and lisas like semi-realistic
endings were like yeah that's how sex
ends but like romantic comedies it's
like you do like
the reasons look one of the reasons I
jump into relationships very fast is
because I'm codependent but the other
reason is I want those stupid romantic
stories and I want to meet the girl at
the coffee shop in Iowa and we should
run away together you know you want that
I think that's a mimetic belief right
where it's you've been acculturated to
believe no that's what I'm saying yeah
100 percent 100 percent but then it
happens and I'm just like you know Ryan
let's go back to the second part of this
question because I think it's so
important here yeah is it possible that
I could be a toxic person to you but
really since a really sincere and lovely
person - to many others yeah I love that
she's considering like am i a toxic
person right yeah and and if you're
asking if you're a toxic person I mean
you just got a look at your behavior
right going back to what you were saying
are you exhibiting toxic behavior
because if you are then yeah it doesn't
matter who might find you lovely you're
still your and going back to what I was
trying to say of if you're exhibiting
toxic behavior and you have someone who
is encouraging that and then you both
kind of you know put your toxic behavior
together and project it out into the
world yeah that that isn't necessarily
positive yeah for me it's like I'm a
much less fun Captain Planet it's
possible to be incompatible without
being toxic with you and I think of
course yeah that's where she's going
here you you may find a partner who is a
lovely person but the two of you are are
incompatible and because you're
incompatible that can lead to toxic
behavior on your part or their part or
both parts now I love what Jamie said a
moment ago about how two broken people
sort of working together to to fix
things and if I were to rephrase that a
little bit now there's a song that I
recommended on the podcast a few weeks
ago by Ken Yeates called two wrongs and
the lyric in there is two wrongs make us
right right and and you know of course
two wrongs don't make a right but if
we're both broken people we can still
enter a relationship and be better off
because of it we well we often say that
that one plus one equals two it's
mathematics right hmm but that's not
always true one drop of water plus one
drop of water is not two drops of water
if you find them together totally and
you also you have to be confident
because look we know this from social
media
a lot of words are being thrown around
recently in the political world with
canceled culture and stuff that are
starting to like lose their meaning so
there is a chance that if poor Eva was
in a relationship and trying her best
and they weren't compatible and she
broke up with the guy that the guy could
be storming out just go yo you're toxic
you ruined this bubble bond it's like
not necessarily it could just be a bad
relationship and now that is just kind
of like a buzzword of this generation
and we're kind of like overusing it
because most relationships if you dive
in or have a recording of a fight like
at some point or another like each one
of you is gonna say something toxic to
each other is gonna say something you
regret is gonna apply apologize
hopefully um but I think the biggest way
you can kind of if you're just focusing
on yourself mm-hmm
and you are as confident as humanly
possible the red flags are there like
when I wasn't confident when I really
was codependent when I would just just
want it to be in a relationships to
define me I remember I tried to have one
of those like hey what's your crazy I'll
tell you my crazy conversations and
first date literally I like brought it
up I was like let's just say what we
need to work on I thought it'd be like
cute and she goes uh she goes um well I
get jealous oftentimes of nothing and
sometimes because of that I've gotten
violent and I was like man we moved in
and then three months three months we
moved in I was together with her in Los
Angeles for two years and guess what she
got jealous often violent always another
but let's talk about jealousy because I
think jealousy is a wasted emotion I
don't think there's ever a positive
outcome for jealousy and in fact uh
right about this in the book Ryan and I
went back and forth on on the virtues
that make a really good relationship and
I can talk about some of those here I
mean to me there are a bunch of
different ways you can you can repair
and strengthen your relationships and
there are good virtues like caring and
love and understanding and tolerance we
can talk about the good virtue on get to
the good stuff what jealousy yeah
jealousy is one of what we call the
thirteen overrated virtues I like that
and so there are there are thirteen
virtues in our life and many of them we
recognize as being like I don't think
there's ever room for jealousy there are
other virtues like empathy which I think
there is room for and we clarified that
in the book but I think it's wildly
overrated
empathy is very far overrated but we
often use the term empathy to mean
compassion and I would even argue the
compassion might be underrated we need
to be far more compassionate for other
people without feeling their exact pain
for sure I don't want my dentist also
feeling the drill in his mouth as he's
drilling into my mouth right right
that's that's true empathy now let me
let me finish up either because we have
to move on but I do want to just finish
out this definition for toxicity because
I think it will set up the rest of this
episode really well
so in the book there's a section called
how to be yourself and I like that that
would be a great just book title by the
way how to be yourself and in this
section we sort of set up toxicity and
it comes right after this section about
finding and powering relationships and
so that's some context for you here now
you might be thinking of course I want
empowering people in my life but how do
I know whether a relationship is good or
bad supportive or toxic growing or dying
maybe in fact by the way that that's a
those are two dichotomies there what's
the opposite of a toxic relationship
it's a supportive relationship there's
not room if you're supportive there's no
room for toxicity right okay so how do
you know how do I know whether a
relationship is good or bad supportive
or toxic growing or dying the short the
short answer is you probably already
know you know if you're wondering
whether a relationship is toxic it
probably is a relationship is toxic when
it's very harmful or unpleasant in a
pervasive or insidious way does the
relationship constantly make you feel
sad agitated or upset anxious angry or
scared guilt-ridden chaste chastised or
regretful then there's a good chance
it's toxic but when a relationship is
truly outstanding you don't wonder at
all you just know it's outstanding it
literally stands out
so I think that's the thing we start
wondering like I've never wondered about
like is my relationship of Becks
toxic because like there hasn't been any
toxic behavior that has led there no I
you said that should kill you and so Eva
I'm gonna send you I can't send you a
copy of this book cause it's not out yet
but we have a book called
essential it's an essay collection with
150 essays about simple living
intentional living twelve different
areas of attentional living one of those
areas has to do with relationships and I
think you'll find a lot of value in that
book it's called essential essays by the
minimalist if you like our podcast it's
it's actually our longest audiobook it's
over six hours so Sean if you want to
give Eva the audiobook version of
essential or if she wants the book book
or the eBook version we're happy to send
those to you as well Ryan Christine has
a question for us Christina from LA how
realistic is it to expect to find a
partner that's on your own frequency
I've got a wonderful partner but he
struggles with untreated depression and
won't acknowledge it he's very good to
me but disagrees with much of my social
justice peaceful kind minimalist ways I
love him but feel drained after spending
much time with him I'm always giving I
want to receive - that's fair yeah yeah
let me just say this I'm gonna set you
up for the set you up for this Jamie I
love him but I feel drained after
spending much time with him I could
actually if you did just were to tweeze
out that sentence yeah the essence
applies to me and Becks in fact it's the
reason that we have a non-traditional
living situation right and it's because
I need copious amounts of alone time now
the key has been setting that
expectation well in advance
now Jamie tell me about Christina's
question here is it realistic to expect
to find a partner that's on your own
frequency so I think what most people do
is they try to have force it right
because they do did you guys ever see
Daniels losses Netflix special jigsaw no
I've heard you recommended you guys
would love it he's such a good comic and
the the Netflix special the last time I
talked to him was responsible for
causing I believe over like fifty
thousand breakups like
divorces and if not him trashing couples
by any means actually I think what he
did my podcast he announced that he was
actually in a relationship and really
happy and it was like you son of a and
but it wasn't trashing that it was
saying that we don't appreciate
ourselves enough and it's so funny as I
get older I realize that all of these
cliches that people tell you are
essentially the keys to life you just
ignore them right so like for years
people are like you have to be alone to
learn how to love yourself before you
love others and I was like that's stupid
and I would move in with some other girl
who would like hit me and then you know
I did what everyone does when they
turned thirty eight and are single for
the first time on Valentine's Day I took
mushrooms and I was like I need to be
alone and it was amazing and I've been
alone and I've been happy and I've been
confident for the first time and I ended
up in so many relationships like she's
describing and I and a lot of times I
just settled and that's what's lost
talks about like we just settled because
we think we somehow found her soul mate
who happened to live in the same
neighborhood as us and like you know and
he was joking around but the second
something gets bad he's out hmm
and there is you know I mean that's kind
of hyperbolic obviously but there is
something to it sounds like she may be
you know for the longest time I just
wanted to fix people I thought that like
I would be the one who comes in and
saves the day and women are actually
known for doing that right there like
attracted to the broken guy and like
I've been the broken guy before to who
I'm sure they want to fix and um I don't
know man I think that it sounds like the
way she's describing it it doesn't sound
like what you were saying with like you
and backs were like you need like a loan
time it sounds like she comes in and
this is what I relate to very much and I
don't have an answer I'm just kind of
rambling but I just related so hard to
this email where it sounds like she for
I'll speak for myself I would come in
and be like hey I know you've been like
really bummed out and like we've been
fighting but like what if we did this
what if we just started like working out
together or what if we like make this
thing or what if we go on a road trip or
what if we and then the like Eeyore on
the other side just like I don't want
you out on whatever so you just feel
like you're just giving and giving and
trying and trying and because you see
there's decency behind that sort of wall
of negativity or depression or whatever
you feel like it's your job to fix it or
you feel like you would be a bad person
if you leave the relationship or selfish
I mean one of my friends is in such a
toxic emotionally abusive relationship
and she's like but I don't want to look
like a monster if I leave but I think so
many people feel that they're breaking
up the family because I I see that in
myself now
now Ryan with with Christina's question
here I mean there's something telling
about the is it realistic to expect
here's what I'll say is don't expect
love you don't just simply fall in love
in fact the when I fell in love with Bex
you fell in love with Mariah when we
stopped looking for in trying to pursue
it in that way however I think it's a
weird expectation because somewhere
around puberty and it's often because
we've been acculturated to do so we
start to expect love in ways that we
don't expect other grand things in life
like we don't expect to just get an
education at Harvard right we don't have
a soulmate diploma waiting for us
somewhere right we don't expect a
million dollars or six-pack ABS what we
do is if we want those things we work at
it right well I think about the us box
that we talk about a lot Josh where you
know you have this box on a relationship
and sometimes we give to that us box and
sometimes we take from it yeah to keep a
count of who has given and who has taken
is is not the best way to approach a
relationship because I think that
ultimately becomes like a zero-sum game
yeah but in the same token when you can
see that the other person isn't giving
to it at all and only taking 100 percent
that is that's an issue I think it's I
mean if I had to recommend something for
Christina it's not like okay this is a
toxic relationship leave your partner
it's more about like Christina you've
got to have a really tough conversation
with your partner right now yeah that's
what I was gonna say and you know that's
where I was going
with the confidence thing which is for
the longest time I would end up in
relationships that would kind of bring
me down and or that I would settle for
or I'd be like you know I want this in
this but I was just so excited somebody
liked me anytime a girl would approach
me to this day this kind of happens like
if some like Instagram model hits me up
I'm like did you DM the wrong account
like did you mean to like some hot other
like Jaime from Brazil or something and
and so I'm always just I was always so
grateful that someone was just there and
ever since I've been single for the
first time in my life this year I am
like I am going to design because like
being single getting dumped guys I
literally my life was bad before Cove it
happened like I got dumped to lost my
cat like all this [ __ ] in the same week
then quarantine happened right and so if
I wanted this narrative of like I'm
alone and Quarantine about I would have
doomed
doom doom you know and instead I was
like I'm going to design the exact life
that I want to have forever so when I
find someone they're either gonna
enhance it or we can enhance enhance
each other's lives but I'm not gonna be
settling and so that's what I did I've
always wanted to wake up at five I've
always wanted to meditate I've always
wanted time to read books to do
jiu-jitsu to go hiking all this stuff
and I do that now and so there where
that ties in with her is I would be in
so many relationships that she described
because I thought that was as good as I
can get now that I have this life that I
sincerely love there have been girls who
have been really cool over and I'm I was
lonely over quarantine I mean they check
off my boxes there were jiu-jitsu girls
or artists or whatever and I have had
zero problem saying no because the
second we would have a conversation
where I would say something important to
me which it sounds like this happens all
the time with her with her boyfriend
with the SJW stuff and they would kind
of like take a shot at it or then I
could be like oh cool you're a cool girl
but this isn't gonna work
and I would peace out immediately but I
never could do that before but let me
say this it's not necessary that you
have the same beliefs in fact no no no
no 100% I think it's helpful that you
have different beliefs in some areas
because it creates some really expansive
converse
that gives you room to grow angry it may
solidify your point of view or it may
change your mind which is one of the
most beautiful things you can do in a
relationship is when you help someone
change their mind or they help you
change yours or they help you strengthen
your position what is key is that you
need to determine whether or not you
have the same values or not so before we
wrap this up I just want to mention this
to everyone if you don't know what your
values are it's gonna be really hard to
get into a relationship and grow in that
relationship we have a free values
worksheet on our website that helps you
identify the four types of values some
specific examples in there of those
types of values I did that work she
didn't just write cash rules everything
around me and I'm happy so the
minimalists comm /v there's a sa there
as well called how to understand your
values that way we don't have to expand
on the values anymore
real quick - with Christina can you
expect to find someone on the same
frequency yes but I don't think anyone
should ever expect to find the perfect
relationship they're out there perfect
relationships are out there but to
expect that is a really poor expectation
even with Josh and I who have been
friends since we were fat little fifth
graders right like there there are
things there are things that we have to
I don't know if it's compromise but we
have to consider each other's feelings
on things yeah it's the same thing with
a romantic relationship and romantic
relationship is even harder because you
live with that person you see them every
day yeah but there's always gonna be
these these small it's compromise the
right word yeah so that I there's a
section in love people use things about
this so - of what I used to think we're
overrated virtues or sacrifice and
compromise so that what used to be 15
over a different virtues but since you
know being in a long-term relationship
and since growing older more mature and
and realizing a few things about myself
I realized that sometimes we we
sacrifice the wrong things and we make
the wrong compromises yes two distinct
terms by the way but yes it's it's okay
to compromise as long as we're not
compromising our values yeah and I'm
sorry I have one more thing for
Christine that that SJW comment yes
you wanna reread it yeah can you say
that again uh
he's very good to me but disagrees with
much of my social justice peaceful kind
minimalist ways okay cool so I wanna be
very clear what Joshua said is important
you should be able to have disagreements
it can heighten you intellectually like
all these things right if I have a
girlfriend and she grew up shooting guns
and I'm like a staunch anti-gun guy I
want to hear from her because she knows
something I don't about gun control and
you could actually have like a really
dope conversation we talked about this
the last time I was on the episode about
how to compromise politically however I
have talked to people who listen to my
podcast who have written in and when
they have partners that Jamie kill
steampunk oh no no now I'm gonna have to
curse I apologize
it is now rebranded and everyone loves
the new name it is much more apt to Who
I am it is called a [ __ ] ups guide to
self-help it's good yeah it's pretty
great and the logo is a cartoon me face
down like so if you have a partner that
makes you feel like stupid for trying to
better your life is where I lose my
patience so if every time she goes you
know hey you don't have to do this but
like I watch this minimalism documentary
and I think I would feel really better
if I like donated my clothes and he
feels guilty for whatever reason or he
starts to project and he goes after her
or if she you know or if she really does
care about a political issue yeah you
know and posts about black lives matter
or whatever and and and he makes her
feel dumb for doing it that is different
than this agreement I've had women write
into the show who have wanted to lose
weight and become healthy and their
partners attack them for it why because
they are unhealthy and they don't want
to fix themselves and I think if you
don't want to fix yourself right cool
but if you're gonna hold back the person
that you claim to love for trying to
better their life or be kinder to other
people or like expand then that's where
I'm just like get out yeah that to me is
toxic
I wonder if Christina can help her
partner maybe look at what the deeper
issue is going on like like how can she
show love and kindness and respect and
help him dig a little bit deeper because
you know
you mentioned jealousy earlier and I
agree to foster jealousy is wasted
energy but jealousy or anger or any of
those negative emotions they are
signifiers and it is it is a it is a
symptom of something much deeper going
on so if you can take that jealousy that
anger that wanting to drag someone down
and really look at the deeper issue like
that's where maybe those emotions it can
be a good a good idea to just dig deeper
was a huge breakthrough like with the
health thing like if that guy would just
admit like look I've been struggling
with food forever mm-hmm and then maybe
they get to do it together it could
actually turn into this really beautiful
thing the problem is when people all
that that's why I just language like
that makes something go off in my head
it's when people double down and it's
just kind of like I'm gonna be miserable
so everyone around me has to be too
instead of like hey this sucks let's
let's help each other yeah we have to
move on but I don't need to get the last
word in here remember this you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you and too
often I think we try to change someone
I'm going to make you a minimalist I'm
going to make you fit I'm going to make
you make more money or whatever of
course you can't change someone you can
inspire them perhaps and that's great I
mean in fact we uses that word partner
in her question a great partnership is
inspirational right in fact if you were
to figure out what does a great partner
look like whether it is your current
partner or someone else Christina maybe
write that down and figure out what
qualities and then of course when you go
through that values worksheet the
minimalists comm /v you can figure out
what type of values does an ideal
partner have and does that fit your
current partner and if not let me say
this I'm not telling you to break up
with him but you'll be fine
without him and here's what I mean by
that I would be fine without backs
I'd be fine without Ryan I'd be fine
without podcast Shawn or Jordan no more
don't you say don't you say it with me
yeah my heart can't take it
and here's the thing I think at first
that sounds callous right we have a rule
in our minimis rule book 16 rules for
living with less which is a free ebook
on our website if you want to check it
out one of those rules are called
willing to walk away rule and in my life
I'm willing to walk away from any
physical item I'm willing to walk away
from a habit from an idea and I'm even
willing to walk away from people and at
first you're like well wait that's
really cold is that compassionate and I
would posit that it is probably the most
compassionate thing is your willingness
to walk away because that means that my
relationship with podcast Shawn or with
my wife or with Ryan is not birthed out
of some sort of pious obligation right
it is birthed out of a daily commitment
in fact Bex and I have this conversation
once a month hey did we still want to be
in this and man that's a hard
conversation the first time you have it
but every time after that it gets easier
and easier now it's just sort of like a
check-in hey and it's more like do we
still want to be in this and if so what
does this look like going forward you
know my insecure self of yesteryear
would have thought you were just a real
jerk but now I look at it and I'm like
oh josh has found a way to really love
who he is as a person and that is how
you get that willingness to walk away
when you can look in the mirror and be
happy with what you're looking at like
that not physically but you know you're
happy with the person that you've become
that's powerful it's so powerful and I
feel like this is like you know I turned
38 in May and this is like the first
year I've really done it but I also find
it's better for that for your partner if
you get rid of them or that person if if
you honestly or just like I'm the only
person holding them together and I have
to fix them and I have to but I'm
miserable it's like you're probably
pretty the misery is probably sensible
you know what I mean like both of you
will probably be better in the long run
but yeah that self-love confidence thing
is the most important I think for sure
Christine I want to give you two tickets
or maybe just one ticket you get to
decide our Los Angeles tour stop this
November we're going back on tour we've
got a bunch of cities all over the US
we're starting with the the west coast
it's called the LES Coast tour I see
on tour I didn't know that sausage to
come on out maybe we even have him as a
special guest at well yeah we could what
surprise I'll do is that I'll intro you
guys okay so maybe it'll be Los Angeles
maybe would be somewhere else in fact if
you don't see a city near you on our
website the man wants calm slashed or
just put your email address in there
we'll never send you spam or junk or ads
but we will notify you if we win we are
coming to a city near you and that's not
just the US and Canada that is worldwide
we've got a new documentary and a new
book coming out so I can imagine we'll
be all over the place soon the
minimalists calm slash tour Christina
come on out get a hug they're free and
transferable we hug it on this tour I
mean I've been hugging a lot recently oh
that's right you're invincible now
that's right I'm invisible you guys are
the only ones that would hug me in Los
Angeles which also means if I have kovat
I know what it's time for our lightning
round what do we do during the lightning
round you know we do we tell Jamie to
shut up when is it going to long this is
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
nine three seven two zero two four six
five four you can even text your emojis
of what you've gotten rid of recently
that has been really fun a lot of people
are texting what they're decluttering
though this is amazing now now those
texts go literally to both Ryan's and my
phone so if you text that phone number
nine thirty seven two oh two four six
five four we respond to as many people
as we can and we even respond to some
people on the podcast now Jamie you
probably recall during the lightning
round this is where Ryan and I and our
guest do our best to answer every
question with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we've
put the text to these minimal Maxim's in
the show notes so you can copy and share
our pit the answers on social media if
you'd like and now you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place minimal
maxims calm all right ills Anne has a
question how do you deal with toxic
people in the workplace I love my job
but the environment is toxic I feel like
leaving but my heart aches when I think
of the great work I'll leave behind let
me give you a pithy answer Jamie and you
you expand for me thank you save me
malice never intersects with meaningful
work oh that was gonna be mine
so I guess I'll just do a long one man
but that is so rough I mean look you
will do your best work if you're happy
right so if you were doing that kind of
work that you get to do in that
environment but in a place where you
feel good about yourself where you're
not have that like you don't have that
sixth grader oh my god it into my
homework and the alarm goes off like
churning in your stomach feeling imagine
what you could do so one maybe there's a
place that you can do that same work
that's less toxic maybe there's a way
you can do it independently but if not
what I would do is make sure that you
have a rigorous self-care program so
before you go to work
how are you starting your day are you
just rushing out of the house and
jumping into this toxic workspace or do
you have an hour to maybe go take a walk
to meditate to stretch to do something
like that's just for you so that you can
show up just like stoic
kick down the door of this office like
kind of like put your headphones in do
your dope work then leave and like yeah
leave go to a kickboxing class do
something else
so that your your your shitty work life
is sandwiched with just taking the best
care of yourself possible yeah it's
interesting I think about the toxic work
environment that I used to be part of in
the telecommunications business and I
compromised because I made really really
awesome money and that was my compromise
I'm like well I'm making this incredible
amount of money it's a toxic work
environment but where else am I gonna be
able to make this money and you actually
sacrificed in a way to you sacrifice
meaningful work so you could make a
certainly a not meaningful paycheck and
that's nice to say that money's wrong
but when it becomes it should be in the
vehicle but it shouldn't be in the
driver's seat yeah I think Ilsan has a
even better excuse than money it's
meaningful work right so she's making
these compromises or he is making these
compromises is he sorry so he's making
these compromises that is allowing him
to do meaningful work but he's still
making the wrong type of sacrifices so
my pithy answer is this the road to
misery is paved
with compromised values it doesn't
matter what the end goal is if you are
constantly compromising your values
you're going to be miserable yeah there
are a few words I wrote down as the two
of you were talking here that just came
to mind because here's the thing
as I said a moment ago malice never
intersects with meaningful work meaning
if you're in a workplace that is toxic
and the behavior of the people is toxic
you're probably not going to do your
best work yeah however those skills are
transferable to somewhere else if you're
working at one telecom company and that
particular work environment is toxic you
can take those skills elsewhere to a
better work yes environment I was just
down at Ramsey solutions and I gotta
tell you it's the best workplace that
I've ever been in the these the people
who run the place it's like you know
Dave Ramsey actually wrote a book about
leadership it's called entre leadership
it's a great book but it's not he took
that and actually created a workplace
with a thousand employees that that
mimics that and they have a zero strike
gossip rule if you're caught gossiping
about anyone you're fired
immediately it's amazing and I always
say that if someone gossips to you they
will gossip about you yeah and I talked
to Dave about this while I was down
there we were working on a project
together
and he he was saying well because if
someone gossips about you they're taking
away one of your most precious resources
your identity yeah you know and I heard
about that guy and and so there are a
few things that I find meaningful work
involves and its focus work and focus
work means a few things like that yeah
you are not distracted you're not busy
it's hard enough that it makes sense to
keep doing but it's it's also not so
hard that you lose interest like if
someone were to bring up quantum physics
I just like eyes oh now cuz it's not for
me Ryan is actually enjoy something like
that so it may it may make sense for
Ryan to dive deep into quantum physics
he could be focused on it for me it
would it wouldn't make much not dive
deep into quantum physics
but I do enjoy talking about yeah you
could go farther than the rabbit hole
than I would because of interest it's
not because I'm I'm less smart than you
necessarily but it just means that I
don't have that same interest level and
the same is true with like reading
Infinite Jest for example that doesn't
interest you that's why I never
recommend that book to people because it
takes you're quite the rational somebody
give me a copy of it where I don't have
to keep flipping to the back of the book
that's all I want that's all I want in
the version that's mine all right a few
other words content so Jamie said you
want to be happy and I agree with that
you want to be happy about happy
happiness is fleeting contentment is not
and so so I would encourage you to find
work that that you are content with and
ultimately that you're joyous whether
you experience joy with because joy
makes room for all the other emotions
there will be drudgery but there is room
for drudgery with joy there will be pain
there will be some struggles meaningful
work requires struggle but joy makes
room for all of those negative emotions
yeah like there are times where I'm
writing a new song or a new stand-up bit
or even like dreading doing the podcast
but then when I get to really think
about what am i doing like oh my god I
get to do this I get to write a song I
get to or when I finally hit the right
chord or the right word in the punch
line or just start the podcast then
suddenly I'm like haha this is dope like
it doesn't mean you're gonna find
something where you're just like happy
all the time and whatever but you should
be your baselines shouldn't be like
dread right all right Jamie Ryan before
we get into our listener tips and our
added value segment today or added value
segment does tie into the whole toxic
people thing so stay tuned for this a
Britney Spears song toxic spoiler alert
actually no but we do have a bunch more
surprise questions and you're gonna love
these how do you let go of toxic family
members oh how do you divorce a close
friend okay what's the difference
between a savable and an unsavable
relationship how do you get past the
trauma and pain of toxic relationships
how did Jamie overcome his recent battle
with suicidal thoughts yeah baby still
here
also we're talking about the toxic
relationship that Ryan and I had that
almost ended our friendship about ten
years ago plus we're going to discuss
two toxic relationships that I had to
end this year personally also uh your
and about Krista Leah's scandal I mean
before you and I were texting about this
last night I've not heard about it oh
you haven't so uh I've got some thoughts
get ready to hear Ryan's horrifying
reaction yes that what happened yeah
it's your good really yeah well we'll
get into it on the maximum we'll also
that and a million more kiss character
and you come true yeah yes all that and
a million more questions for Jamie kill
Steen oh and uh there's one thing it's
on the table right now you can't see it
if you're watching us on camera you'll
be able to see it on the maximal I
purchased something Ryan don't say what
it is because it's on the table you
purchased something you're a phony
did I shouldn't have purchased this year
and I tell you that I regret it and I'm
going to get rid of it and I'm gonna
tell you how on the Mac you'll never
guess what Josh is gonna declutter next
so am i saying bye to the non-paid REO
just wait a second so there's room for
that but we're almost there yeah so this
week that's all that the rest everything
all the questions we just discussed that
those will be on the maximal episode
this week you can check out it's on the
minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast and it's
just a couple bucks and it's the most
honest way for the minimalist to earn an
income because we don't believe in
advertisements so we make money only if
you find value in and support what we
create head on over to the minimalists
comm slash support by the way that also
keeps this a hundred percent
advertisement free so thank you to all
of our patreon supporters head on over
there to the minimalists com a slash
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app Ryan what else you got for us this
week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
my name is Nick cozy and from Evansville
Indiana and I just have been listening
to episode 55 on critics and I just
wanted to
a quote that I heard for my friend and
he got this from his grandpa and it's
all one of my all-time favorite quotes
now and it is don't take criticism from
someone you wouldn't take advice from
hello this is DC from Minneapolis
Minnesota and I just want to quickly
recommend something that added a lot of
value to my life for a while it's a
website called unrolled me you and rol
LM e and you just enter your email
address and it pulls up every single
email list you're subscribed to and then
you can easily look at the list and just
click unsubscribe from all these email
lists that's a lot easier is I'm
scrolling to the bottom of an email and
finding the unsubscribe button so yes
that's helped me a lot lately
all right Jamie now this is the part
where you say nice things about us right
read something go I've nothing to say
listen to my podcast and only mine I
agree thank you guys for listening to
this show I mean I think like it's been
so cool not cool but I mean like
quarantines been really hard for a lot
of people and you know I think shows
like yours are really really really
important and I've even had to like some
of the more like comedy heavy podcasts
and whatever I've actually had to take
them out of my rotation on like a almost
like a toxic friendship where because I
was alone during quarantine oh here's
some advice if there are people who are
still like alone in quarantine you know
how they talk about like you are the
five people you surround yourself with
or whatever if you don't have people you
can make that what you are taking into
your brain
whether it be books whether it be
podcasts because when I'm listening to
some of those comedy podcasts that are
just talking about like getting like
trashed on the road and like sleeping
around or whatever there's still that
little high school part of me that's
like oh that's cool that's what I want
to do and when I listen to podcasts like
your guys I'm like ah I should just be a
good person um so thank you to everybody
and yeah my podcast is a [ __ ] ups guide
to self-help you can go to Jamie Kellam
podcast calm or a [ __ ] ups guide calm
I'm verified and cool on Twitter and
Facebook however I only enjoy Instagram
and would like to build that up so
unfollow me on Twitter
and follow me on instagram at the Jamie
kill Steen where I make weird little
comedy videos and post motivational
stuff there great man you're on I love
you brother I love you guys so much
thanks for your minute let's talk about
our added value this week I've been
reading this book by Lionel Shriver she
is one of the most just gorgeous
she writes some of the most gorgeous
prose that I've read in a long time
she wrote that book called we talked
about this on a maximum episode but just
I just touched on a brief I didn't
really talk about the book at all she
wrote some thoughts about Kevin which it
would turn into a film which oh yeah oh
yeah that film was best yeah yeah the
soul is the book okay and so she has a
new book out called the motion of the
body through space and it's sort of
about aging and but it's and also it's
about this marriage so this is aging
couple they're both in their 60s and
their bodies they're both really healthy
and physically healthy have been most
their lives but their bodies are
breaking down and there's some sort of
toxic resentment between the two of them
and it manifests because it's in third
person so there's a narrator who's sort
of inside their thoughts and it's great
to see the inner workings of toxicity
among two seemingly good people I want
to read that it's a really good book I
will put a link to it in the show notes
also a link to Jamie's podcast in the
show notes as well the book is by Lionel
Shriver it's called the motion of the
body through space and real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist my writing class is finally
coming back it's back baby
Oh sick 2048 hours only how to write
better org we're gonna open up
enrollment at the end of July but go
ahead and put your email address in
there now we'll notify you it's the
first hundred students what we do I only
do this class two sometimes three times
a year and so this will be our summer
class enrollment opens for 48 hours or
until the class fills up well notify you
via email also if you put your email
there at how to write better org is the
email or is the the website you'll get
the free ebook eleven ways to write
better you really miss a good
opportunity to name it like how to write
best I was gonna write oh you're gonna
name it how to write good or how to
write better write good
you can follow the minimalist on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visits the minimalists
comm / tour to find a city near you have
a question if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for a podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at the
middle is calm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com / the minimalist
let me know about my facial hair and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at the
minimalists comm you also receive our
simple Sunday emails whenever we send
those and if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite is toxic that's great alright
y'all thanks for listening we'll see you
next time and minimus